en el norte de kosovo reciente serbios
cruzan un cordón de soldados de la otan
desplegados en el país a continuación
intentaron tomar el ayuntamiento local
antes de ser dispersados
estas escenas tuvieron lugar en tres
localidades del norte de kosovo región
predominantemente poblada por serbios
desde el viernes los manifestantes piden
la destitución de los alcaldes de etnia
albanesa
solo tenemos dos peticiones en primer
lugar que nos dejen entrar en el
ayuntamiento Y en segundo lugar que se
vayan mientras ustedes estén aquí
nosotros estaremos aquí pueden
obligarnos a salir pero volveremos
estos concejales de origen albanés
acaban de tomar posesión de su cargo
fueron designados en las elecciones
locales organizadas por las autoridades
kosovares las elecciones fueron
boicoteadas en gran parte por los
votantes en su mayoría serbios y sólo
votaron 1500 de los 45.000 electores
inscritos
No dejen entrar a esos falsos alcaldes
porque han obtenido 50 votos ni siquiera
los albaneses han votado
Serbia rechaza en la independencia
proclamada en 2008 por kosovo antigua
provincia Serbia tras el estallido de
los enfrentamientos el pasado viernes el
presidente puso al ejército en alerta
máxima cerca de la frontera
Hace unas horas atacó directamente al
Primer Ministro kosovar
pues lo observan los serbios de kosovo y
sé cómo se sienten y lo difícil que es
para ellos a que no entren en conflicto
con la otan porque eso es lo que más
desea Alvin curti según curti unos 50
serbios resultaron heridos en los
últimos enfrentamientos por su parte la
otan ha registrado más de 25 heridos
entre sus soldados